can you give us any more guidance as to
how many British citizens you're able to
get out of Sudan over the last 24 hours
so over the last 24 hours we had three
flights coming in from Sudan with around
about 200 240 people on board and about
170 of them have already boarded a plane
back to the UK
priority who are the people that you're
getting out first
so when we started this uh this
operation we were proactively reaching
out to those that we had judged to be
the most vulnerable and invited them to
come to the airport for the the flights
out but as soon as it became clear that
there was a huge amount of demand and
that this route was viable we've
essentially opened it up and invest all
British Nationals who feel able and
comfortable to make their way to the why
they say the Airfield to come and people
are coming and pretty much being put on
a first come first serve basis
will they get into the Airfield
before you go
this has been a challenge and to be
honest this is the reason why it's
taking a little while to set this
operation up the situation on the ground
in Khartoum is very very volatile and
the security of the route wasn't at all
clear it's only since we've had this
latest 72-hour ceasefire which isn't a
full ceasefire but least it's a lull in
the fighting that we've been confident
that we can enact this uh this route and
essentially ask people if they feel
comfortable to make their own way to the
Airfield we don't really have any other
way to get them there ourselves but what
we found is that people have been able
to make the the journey to the Airfield
and and more and more are making it
safely and we're expecting a lot more to
come today
and in terms of the numbers
um is is it the the fear over over that
Journey that's preventing people coming
to the Airfield do you think
I think people are coming to the
Airfield now I mean partly that first
few flights were the trial and people
have seen that this does work and it is
possible and they are getting back to
the UK and I think today we're expecting
a lot more to come and so we've had a
lot more people come to the Airfield and
we're expecting a number or more flights
to bring Brits out of the danger out of
Sudan here to Cyprus and then on to the
UK
so how many how many do you think you're
going to be bringing out in the next 24
hours for example
so we've got a number of flights
potentially lined up it does partly
depend upon how many make their way to
the airport we had roughly 200 yesterday
we're expecting multiple hundreds today
but it does partly depend upon the
logistics at the airport I mean every
flight that has come to to Cyprus has
been later than it had planned because
the processing and the handling and the
the sort of getting people onto the the
air planes is a bit more complicated in
that very volatile environment so I'd
hope we'd have multiple hundreds coming
to to Cyprus today
because other flights not they're not
full are they at the moment when they're
coming back
some of them have been full so we've had
three flights the first was actually a
logistic flight that wasn't meant to
take any passengers but because we had
Brits ready to come we put 39 people on
that flight and it came late last
evening two came in the early hours of
this morning they have a capacity of
about uh just over 100 and they had
about 100 on on both of those flights
okay so what happens after they get to
lanika you said some have already been
been forwarded onto the UK
yeah so we have set up this operation in
cooperation with the government of the
Republic of Cyprus who are doing a
fantastic job to assist us they actually
have a fair amount of experience in
managing large-scale evacuations because
they were doing that in 2006 during the
Lebanon uh evacuation so they have a
quite well tested and tried plan here
this is why we're flying here they've
got a center for receiving all of the
evacuees from Sudan they process them
quite quickly they've got Red Cross
Medical Services food water anything
that people need and then once the
immigration on the security formalities
are done we the UK government are
chartering planes to put the Brits back
on those planes and bring them back to
the UK so the first flight took the bulk
of the the 200 or so who were here
already this morning and we're expecting
one or two more flights to come this
afternoon from Sudan and then another a
few more flights to go back to the UK in
the same way and has that first flight
landed back in the UK do you know or is
it still in the air
I think it's still in the air because it
wasn't that long ago that it left but I
don't have confirmation of that okay
there are questions about the cost of
all of this of course it's incredibly
important to keep British citizens safe
but but some will say well hang on you
know a lot of these people were in Sudan
by choice yes the the fighting was was
perhaps unexpected that it flared up
again but but why how do you feel about
the fact that the cost of this operation
to the British government
so these are British Nationals
the British government generally
speaking wants to serve its Nationals
and we're doing that now I was as you
said the the former British ambassador
to Sudan and I have to say my experience
there was one that filled me with a huge
amount of awe and admiration for the
Sudanese people many of whom are British
Sudanese or British there the revolution
that took place in 2019 against the
30-year dictatorship of Omar Bashir was
a an inspirational experience young
people women standing up for their
rights and for the right to choose their
own leadership and in a way what's
happening now is a massive massive
tragedy not just on a human level but
also for the future course of this
country because there was such a moment
of Hope and inspiration and aspiration
for a different type of Sudan which this
this needless fighting between these two
military groups has absolutely quashed
so from my perspective from my
experience uh I think this is worth the
money I mean how much does the life cost
and indeed it and and finally how long
do you think you're going to be able to
keep these shuttling flights going
backwards and forwards will it purely be
on the security situation that
determines how long you will do it
I think that's going to be the main
factor so we're hoping that this lull in
fighting continues and we can get as
many uh Brits who want to come out as as
they can if it does go on I would
imagine this will go on for a few days
but it probably depends upon the
situation the ground partly how many
Brits come to the Airfield and also the
sort of logistics around the flights
that we can get out there but I'd
imagine this would continue unless
something dramatic happens on the ground
for the next few days